her name is engraved on a satellite that
is now in the bottom of the atlantic
ocean
it used to be in space
and now it's at the bottom everyone
please welcome mallory
what did the janitor say when he came
out of the closet
supplies
that has nothing to do with my talk i
just wanted to loosen you up before i
get a little bit sacrilegious about some
things so
hello and welcome to my favorite
conference and a few years ago actually
at the last time it was live
i spoke at dcr about dashboards and i
mentioned this
dreamboat of a package that makes
beautiful visualizations called high
charter
that's a morning a visualization theme
which is great
but it has come to my attention that
you still don't use it so
while i have the floor
we're going to talk about high charter
okay what is it and why
so high charter is an r wrapper for the
beloved high charts javascript
library
makes interactive plots that are very
pretty and very versatile
and
interactive plots
gets you
many plots in one which is
very convenient like
are you tired of passing plots back and
forth between somebody trying to get it
to be
just you know pretty enough and just
useful enough adding labels to things
and modifying it so that someone can
take it to someone else more important
than you in a meeting that you're not
invited to
well i can't help you with most of that
but i can at least shorten the iteration
of plot edits by
using something that is inherently going
to be more useful
so
the other convenience is that it's
syntactically similar to gg plot so it's
not really so bad to learn
all right why will you like it
same reasons it's pretty it's versatile
it's interactive and it's not even hard
and interactive plots save you time
that is uh
one of the biggest things that that you
gain from this
so no more labeling bar heights uh
you can hover over top of things and it
populates with more context
and without cluttering the space
no more plotting every single
combination of comparisons because you
can click to turn things on and off
um you can allow for zooming so
arbitrary zoom so if you have some
timeline you're like here it is here's
the here's a whole year and they okay
but can i also get one with a one month
and then also get one with that well you
can do anything you want here it is you
can zoom
it's great
also
people will respect you
that it's uh key
so
sorry having a tech issue
and the best part is you get to use r so
you don't have to learn javascript in
order to get all these uh wonderful
things
so why you should use it
there is a war on r and it is time to
show off
and we did not wage this war
but
um
moving on
but seriously why
so highcharter makes our look good and
you want to address your data to impress
we all benefit when you make our look
good because your company will want to
keep hiring our users
if they see they don't see what goes
into it they see the output so if you're
always handing off beautiful stuff then
that's going to make r look good and
they'll be more likely to think of r as
uh you know not let python take over for
example that will make more people want
to learn are
and people expect fancy visualizations
now so
just in the modern world
everyday people gamification
leaderboards all of that
they
everyone is interacting with beautiful
visualizations every day you expect a
plot on when you're looking at it online
to be able to interact with it you don't
expect a static png just in the world
anymore so
people expect these things to be nice
so also it really helps you justify r in
a sea of python users so
i always say oh yeah sure i i can do
python that's fine that's great but r is
for research python's for production
which has great alliteration so
so use it but also for me it's
definitely true
for me i mean i say
whatever you're the best at the most
efficient at that's probably going to be
what you want to use for
getting something done on the side or
researching something before you want to
put it into production but
uh because i can produce really
beautiful visualizations and dashboards
nobody seems nobody cares that i'm the
only one using r
and that's been true at quite a few
companies that i've been at where
everyone else just expected me to use
python for everything and i just on the
side i just make all this stuff with r
and everybody likes what i make so they
let me keep doing it and don't really
ask questions so r is a way or high
charter has really helped me justify
using r instead of python
and that's what i'm into
uh yeah also again we cannot let the
python browse win so
all right a guided tour
from pluses to pipes
okay
so here we have
a dashboard we're going to walk through
a tutorial
and how is that
i need a zoom all right
i might have to zoom back in and out a
little bit but that seems acceptable for
looking at code all right so we're
looking at the diamonds
package and just doing some subsets to a
few of ideal premium good okay great so
first we'll compare ggplot and high
charter
for a few things
so
first let's see this plot um side by
side this is the gg plot without really
any extra
things added to it and this is the same
idea the high charter version of this
plot without adding any extra bells and
whistles just adding a title and all
that so this is what i'm talking about
with the interactivity and the hover
and where you no longer would have to
label the bar heights it's like i can't
exactly see it line up can you paste in
oh that's terrible so here you just
hover great and you can see that you can
turn things off and on so this is what i
was talking about if you want to compare
specific things and you don't have to
like oh can we say it with just those
two or just those three it's like you
can do it yourself there you go
now let's compare the code
so
we have ggplot data plus gmbar so we're
like okay we have the skeleton uh now we
want to add a bar and then it's
aesthetics and you populate it with what
you actually want it to plot you want it
to plot color and fill equals cut
meaning like group that's a group by cut
position dodge so they're stacked their
bars all next to each other okay and
then just adding a title so really the
core of it is those first two lines
where we say you have first of all we're
gonna do a plot okay great and then you
say what you're gonna add to it
very much the same idea over here so you
start with high chart pipe um you know
that one
and then
still same kind of one liner so the next
whoopsies
so instead of gmbar it's hc ad series
and this one will work for all different
types of series you specify what type
you want uh in the high charter world
the type is column so if you want
vertical it's column bar would actually
you could assign bar here and that would
be horizontal instead
so the main differences here is that
saying fill equals cut automatically
this automatically counted
uh kind of did like a histogram style by
these groupings so
that count was automatic um i don't
think that you're not gonna want to do
that here um when you have group buys so
i first summarized the counts
and that was really the only added step
that i did but that's usually not
necessary just depends on what kind of
data you have going into it
so this idea basically
you can see
really not exceptionally different code
color
is it the x i specified the y is taught
um that was the total and group by cut
just group equals cut okay
doesn't look scary looks a lot like gg
plot just where ggs are you swap them
out with hc's a lot of the time
so okay not so bad and then uh there's
this kind of mapping that i have here
that
explains what i just said all right now
let's stack them okay great
so the only thing that changed for the
ggplot is
position equals stack instead of
position equals dodge
same kind of idea in high charts but
you specify it in a slightly different
way you say stacking so now there is
this stacking attribute and you can
assign it to normal and that would be
normal stacking there you go
same thing so position equals stack
stacking equals normal
cool all right so far very similar
all right next um all right now i'm
going to move the high chart legend just
to show you some legend
based code because sometimes you want to
mess with that and to get it to match to
be in the same place
so here we have uh
hc legend so that has its own uh little
you know uh layer that you can add in
and there's a line equals right vertical
line equals middle layout equals
vertical it's going to get you
it
yep cool so
not hard
all right uh oh yeah fill opacity okay
so one thing i i always i do change a
lot so a lot of the things i'm gonna
talk about are just things that i end up
editing a lot or i always want to figure
out how to change so i don't and i get
i'm very into aesthetics than like the
look of things i want to to be pretty
and i don't really
and i don't like the fully solid colors
all the time usually i want to mess with
the the opacity so
so here now i'm just doing a high charts
example
but there it is right in the hc ad
series you can change it directly in
their
opacity equals 0.75
and look at that and now it's not so
bold
all right so
this is all pretty pretty
straightforward not super hard not super
different especially from uh gg plots so
now let's see some other examples with
some lines
okay now we're looking at the grunfeld
investment firm value data because i
wanted to
well it was useful i needed some some
panel data so
um 200 observations i think 10 different
firms spanning over some period of time
great great
that's available in the plm package
okay first markers this one comes up a
lot so
the markers that you get automatically
with a line plot are massive i
think i'm like find them
this is ugly this is terrible so
as an extreme i made them go away now
let's see how that was done
so first to just make the line chart
it's the exact same idea you just say
line instead of where previously i'd
said column
and then
this a i always call it h case
i know that it's like like aes is for
aesthetics but if you say it the way
it's supposed to be said
then it's ass so i just say ace instead
so h case um is the
hc version of
ace aes
okay
uh
right there it is all right
so one of the main differences that
you'll see is that made it a little bit
hard to learn for me a while back
is the
nest is there's like there's nested
attributes so
here in plot options
i have line equals
list the marker equals list radius
equals zero so these are the aesthetics
uh are kind of in a it's coming from a
javascript library and so all these
things are nested so where i say line i
actually could have said series but if i
have multiple series in this thing
multiple different things i'm adding on
layering onto this plot then i want to
be specific about which
um
which series i'm trying to modify so i'm
saying okay for that line plot all right
great now there's going to be a lot of
different things that i can that i can
edit for the line plot therefore it's
going to go in a list and now i'm in the
list great now what about the line plot
the marker i want to change the marker
okay well there's a lot of things you
could change so there's going to be a
list the thing what do i want to change
the radius okay so i set the radius to
zero and now we have uh you know no
markers
cool so that's the idea that hap that's
what comes up with the like that's the
main difference is this nested list
business but when you see the mapping
from where it came from it makes a lot
of sense
so this i i started using this in in
2016 or 2017 and there were very few
examples and you still might find that
the ease the best examples that you can
find
um of exactly what you want to do are
actually in the high charts original
javascript um
documentation
but
even though it looks intimidating it's
actually this is how i learned a lot of
this stuff i just figured out how to
what that mapping was i'm like okay if
the javascript looks like this then the
r must be this does it work and it
generally did so here you can see this
is
a javascript for some chart whatever i
didn't care about the surrounding things
i just cared about this plot options
because i knew they were modifying the
marker radius and so i see plot options
zooming in on that section that there's
a list and then series list marker list
and it maps to exactly the same kind of
thing
those are
structurally just about the same so
that's very useful when you can't find
an example of what you want exactly the
high charts documentation is elaborate
and it's very useful and once you notice
like oh actually that's not so hard i
can i can basically guess what what the
command is going to be and i have had
a lot of success doing it that way
so fun but i'm also trying to spare you
a bit of that by by providing some of
this code which will obviously be on my
github um after
all right facilitating many comparisons
sometimes like when i worked for npr and
i was making something for a bunch of
different podcasts and we wanted to be
able to compare specific podcasts
you don't want to it's it's you don't
want to bombard someone with 30
different lines when you know they're
probably going to be comparing only one
or two of them at a time so you can set
visible equals false
so that you can start with a blank slate
and then go in and start comparing
things so that and it's so simple it's
just visible equals false
right there
so h chart
h chart does the same kind of thing as
hc ad series it's essentially a
shorthand for
you could say hi chart pipe hc ad series
or most of the time you can just swap
out both of those with h chart and
specify all the same kind of thing
all right so
that is really cool and can be very
useful custom hover text this is
probably the most
this is one of the things that i love
the very most and use the most and
saves
saves a lot of time and adds a lot of
context
so if you want to change the hover text
so here you can see this is what you get
automatically it says 1942 um four
so referencing firm four the firms are
just ids
and then whatever the value is that i'm
plotted here but what if i want to add
more information like what if i want to
know some of the other things
um like gross investment capital like
what if i wanted to know those things
sure let's pretend okay so you can
modify the hover text and it is very
simple so you give them names the things
that you want to how you want
want to have displayed you name them
and then you do a
little sprint f
that refers to the column names of those
things you would like to visualize
and this there's some formatting that
i've done here to cut off numerics at
two decimal places and that's what that
point business is about but i'm not
going to get into it all right and then
you create the tooltip by just combining
those two things so tool tip table
x y x is the names y is the values and
then you use it
so all i've changed from my previous
plot is
pipe hd tooltip
use html is true and i
point format i point to the the name of
the tooltip
and then we have a lot more information
so now
it is so so so easy to just append all
that information and how the amount of
use you can get out of that to be able
to
not clutter up a plot but then able to
provide a whole bunch of context just uh
when you hover over it's awesome so that
is probably one of the biggest selling
points to me because it's like the fact
that you can hover is
is so great like that compared to a just
printed png and you're like want to give
me more context give me more context but
you won't you're just static but so
being able to modify the hover is
awesome
all right so this last example
is very fancy but it actually wasn't
that hard and i'm going to show you so
this is from a data set that i made up
well it's based on a real data set that
i was doing a progression of models and
getting the
precision and recall and sort of
plotting the trade-off between precision
and recall of these
many iterations of this model so i had
18 iterations and there was a baseline
performance for precision and recall and
then there was a goal so the point was
okay can we reach this goal through this
particular uh path of model iterations
and so i wanted to visualize the
progress of this thing um so i made this
super cool plot here that shows the
precision and the recall and how they're
changing over the
um each iteration of the model and the
goal up here in green so if it if any of
the lines go above gold the gold then
they would turn green if they were in
um
in between if they were below the gold
they were just normal color and if they
were below the baseline they went gray
so
i'm not going to have a
time really to walk through each piece
of this but it will be in the code and
the idea is as long as you know what
things are called then you can modify
them but sometimes it's hard to know
what to even search for what things are
called so in this case um
for like the horizontal lines for
example are um
oh yeah all right so coloring is called
zones right yeah zones so if you want to
try to actually change the color of the
line as it hits different y values that
is called zones and
um
that's
i'm just going to stop there
but this code is going to be available
on github
and please admire how beautiful this
plot is and it wasn't even hard
[Applause]